l
est mort, il avait 87 ans,
parcours de cette vie
exceptionnelle avec Geneviève
Asselin.
- La guerre, la guerre,
c'est pas une raison
pour se faire mal!
- C'est avec "La Guerre
des Tuques" que le producteur
connait son premier succès
en 1984. Film culte au Québec,
il se vend aussi dans 125 pays,
c'est le premier d'une longue
série des "Contes pour tous",
des longs métrages qui
connaitront de nombreux succès
populaires internationaux,
tels "Opération beurre de
pinottes", "La grenouille
et la baleine",
ou "Bach et Bottine".
- Si Bottine s'en va,
je m'en vais aussi.
- C'est après des études en
enseignement, et en faisant
un voyage autour du monde dans
les années 1960, que Rock Demers
se découvre un intérêt pour
le cinéma d'ailleurs.
Et à son retour, il crée
la compagnie Faroun pour
distribuer des films étrangers
ici. Déjà, il a ses critères
de qualité.
ROCK DEMERS,
père des "Contes pour tous"
- Disons, un des éléments
essentiels que j'aime à
retrouver dans les films que
je présente aux jeunes,
c'est des films d'abord qui
collent avec la réalité,
mais des films dans lesquels
il y a un certain merveilleux,
une certaine poésie.
- Son intérêt pour le septième
art l'amène aussi à s'engager
dans les institutions vouées
à son développement.
C'est ainsi que Rock Demers
devient un des fondateurs de
la cinémathèque québécoise.
- C'est un endroit où on pouvait
conserver les oeuvres dans
leur intégralité. Ça échappait
au contrôle de la censure.
- Il est aussi de l'équipe qui
met sur pied le premier festival
de cinéma non-compétitif
au Québec, le Festival
international du film de
Montréal, qui connaitra huit
éditions annuelles
jusqu'en 1967.
- Tous les films seront des
premières nord-américaines.
- Mais c'est dans le cinema
jeunesse que Rock Demers trouve
son filon et développe
sa passion. Il décide d'en
produire et fonde, en 1980,
la compagnie Les Productions La
Fête. Il en sortira 30 films en
une trentaine d'années.
Une oeuvre saluée par
des dizaines de prix au pays
et à travers le monde.
- Bien, c'est que là, on part
une compagnie puis....
- Avec ses films, Rock Demers
voulait tisser des liens entre
les générations et entre
les cultures, et toujours passer
aux enfants son message
sur la beauté de la vie...
- La vie, faut pas se raconter
d'histoire, c'est pas facile,
mais ça vaut la peine d'être
vécu.
- Geneviève Asselin,
Radio-Canada, Mo